ryan it's so good to see you buddy
hi sangeet how are you i'm really really
good and i just want to say i absolutely
loved your speech at the wsj innovator
award i think you need a t-shirt that
says blake is a genius
i think i need a tattoo really yeah
i'm so excited about this film because
two of my favorite guys you and dwayne
coming together for an adventure and i i
realized that you were the sexiest man
alive before him so now that you've
spent a lot of time with him what makes
him one of the most sexiest man alive
i'm glad you asked me that you know it
would be my reflex to give you a kind of
a joke answer but i'm not going to do
that uh you know what what makes dwayne
the sexiest man alive honestly it's his
vulnerability he has he has access to a
great wellspring of his own
vulnerability and i and i i love that
about him i think that's very it's also
a wild juxtaposition from his kind of
persona as this you know
ultra macho kind of overly you know
everything sort of big bigger is better
but in you know on the inside he's
incredibly vulnerable and and that's
something i think is really beautiful
i thought you're gonna do a joke
no i'm saying you're right i've let the
team down i realize that i've completely
let the team down um yes the back of his
head does look like a penis there i'll
give you that but uh but uh yeah
and this film's about treasure find the
biggest treasure you can i'm curious to
know what is that biggest treasure in
your life that is i guess priceless
priceless i mean i'd be an idiot not to
say
you know um my children i know that
would be the the popular answer but um
but you know i have a 10-speed bike for
when i was a kid and that no
no no my kids i i would do anything for
my kids uh i
anyone who knows me knows that i will uh
forsake sleep on when i'm traveling
somewhere usually i try to get back same
day so i can put them to bed and that
kind of stuff so i i would do just about
anything for my kids
i know and i realized all of us have
girls that have two girls you guys all
have three girls as well which is so
crazy yeah it's i i don't know anything
different now i'm the youngest of four
boys so growing up i know what that kind
of chaos is like but having three girls
has been amazing i yeah i wouldn't
change a thing
i love that and in the film you have all
these little liners you're you're
whistling indiana jones you're making
fun of the mock neck or is the
turtleneck i don't know what's the
difference but uh and then you do the
vin diesel joke i mean did you have
different versions of it or was that on
the script
no that was a run i did a run of like
nine i remember i wrote them down and
about nine different jokes there
and yeah and i just let them they just
chose the vin diesel one but there was
yeah there was a whole bunch of them
there i can't remember them now but they
were preposterous yeah
so you were the culprit behind it
yeah i'm fine to take credit for that
i'm not you know not it's not some sort
of like character assassination it's a
it's a cat's j it's a cat's joke i mean
uh but uh but yeah it was it's fun and
it acknowledges and plays with the
cultural uh landscape there between
those guys i don't know sort of the sort
of thought it was fun
that's awesome and the fact is you just
turned 45 happy people later birthday
right away think about betty white she's
turning 100 next year we're celebrating
her in a big way at et canada i mean you
got to work with her what what would you
say about her being one of the most
funniest people in the world
it's amazing to see that kind of
longevity obviously it's just a huge
strength of spirit there and she's she's
really a truly special and an
international treasure but i just love
that she still has her sense of humor
and not just her sense of humor but her
like she'll work blue still i'll never
forget the last day shooting the
proposal as she was saying goodbye to
the crew she said that this was the most
fun i've ever had in my entire life and
she left the room and then stepped back
and said standing up and then left the
room again i mean like you know this is
a this is a woman and that was in her
late 80s i guess she was still working
blue
and i love that it cracks me up and you
know i i she has a special place in my
heart for sure i love that and ryan i
just want to say thank you for
everything you've brought us with your
your movies and you're going to
sabbatical leave and i'm happy with your
jib now but you are awesome and enjoy
your time
thank you for the kind words
you